PROFESSOR: This is
Dr. MATLAB, lecture 3.
If you're using MATLAB on the
command line for enough time,
you realize that you really
want to save a bunch of commands
in a file and then execute
all those commands in one go.
This helps you so that
if you have typos,
you can correct the typos
without introducing new ones.
It also allows you to
create large pieces of code
that call each other and really
have complicated projects.
To see how this works,
we need an example.
What we'll do is generate
the Fibonacci sequence.
So in the Fibonacci sequence,
the first two terms are 1.
And then each term is the sum
of the previous two, like that.
Notice that this will
create a new term
in f that will be the
sum of the very last one
plus the second-to-last one.
Here it created 2,
the sum of 1 plus 1.
If we run that
command again, it will
generate 3, and then 5, and
then 8, and then 13, et cetera.
So now I want to take these
three important lines--
this one, this
one, and this one--
and create a file that
will do all of this
and put this line
inside a loop so that it
does that, say, 20 times.
To do that, I open
the History browser.
I want it to be docked.
And it's docked.
And here I find my commands
that I issued here.
I'm going to select all of
them, the three commands,
right click, and copy.
So now I've copied
these three commands.
Over here, I can
open a new script.
The first thing I want to
do is get rid of this bar
because it uses up a
lot of important space.
So now I have a bit
more space, and I
can close this command
history because I
have copied those commands.
And now I'm going to paste.
After I've pasted
this, of course,
I need to clean up a bit.
So I'm going to add semi-colons
at the end of these commands
because I don't need
to see the output.
And I'm going to
add a for loop that
will calculate the first
20 to the next 20 terms.
So I'm going to
have 22 in total--
two from here, and then
another 20 from here.
At the end, add a
Tab character just
for alignment to
make it easy to read.
And now at the end, I will
just display f like that.
Because everything
else is suppressed.
I need to save this.
I need to select a
place to save it.
The default is in
Documents, Matlab.
I want to save it
in a different place
to demonstrate what the path is.
So to do this, I
open a new folder.
I will call it
Scripts, for example.
So now this script
is under Matlab.
And then in Scripts, I
will call this file Fibbo.
It already is an M file,
which is the extension
that you need to have.
Fibbo stands for Fibonacci.
And I save it.
And now I go to my command
line and I try to run it,
and it doesn't run.
And the reason it
doesn't run is that Fibbo
is sitting inside a
subdirectory of Matlab.
And my current directory,
found by typing CD, is Matlab.
So I'm sitting in Matlab.
Fibbo is sitting in Scripts,
which is inside Matlab.
We can see this by looking
at the current folder.
So here's the current folder.
Under Scripts, there's
Fibbo, but we are not there.
We're up here in Matlab.
So there's two ways
we can solve this.
We can either change
directory to Scripts--
for example, by
double clicking here.
Now our current
folder is Scripts.
Now if we go here
and call if Fibbo,
it works, and it
calculates the 22 terms
of the Fibonacci sequence.
We could have also done
this from the command line.
Here I'm going to
go back to MATLAB.
And I can say change directory
scripts, Tab completion.
And now I'm in Scripts,
and I can call Fibbo again.
Another thing I could do--
going back to MATLAB--
is to add scripts to the path.
What is the path?
Let's see.
So if I type path, I get
a list of directories,
a long list of
directories that Matlab
uses in order to look for
the commands that I issue.
All the commands
that you issue will
have to be in one of these
directories for MATLAB
to look at them, or in
the current directory.
So you see that the Matlab
directory, the Documents Matlab
directory, is
always in the path.
That's a default.
But you can add
to the path whatever you want.
So for example, I can
add add path scripts.
Now that I've done that,
let's look at the path again.
Scripts is in there.
And if I try to run Fibbo, then
it works even though I'm here.
The way I've written it,
it will look in Scripts
as a relative directory and
not as an absolute directory.
If I want an
absolute directory, I
would have had to say add path
slash Users slash Documents
slash Matlab slash Scripts.
This is a different path
because this is the exact one.
Let's look at the path now.
Here we have the absolute
and the relative scripts.
At any case, if you want to see
whether Matlab can see a file,
you can type which Fibbo,
and then MATLAB tells you,
if it sees it, which file
it actually is going to.
So if you have the same file
name in different directories,
both of which are in
your path, the first one
that Matlab encounters will
be the one that MATLAB calls.
Let's do one more thing.
So let's see what happens when
we actually hide something.
This can be
potentially dangerous.
Let's open a new file.
And we'll say-- it
doesn't do much.
Let's say it says x equals 1.
And we're going
to save this file,
but we're going to be a
bit insidious about it,
and we're going to call it Sin.
And we're saving it in
the Matlab directory.
So we're saving a file called
Sin in the Matlab directory.
And now if I do sin of 3,
I get a very strange error.
Notice that it's a function.
But if I would have
called it sine,
I would have gotten
the 1, because that
would have been the script.
So you have to be careful
with things like this.
And I would recommend
not having such a file
in your current folder.
You can also execute a file from
the graphical user interface
by clicking this button.
If that file is not in the path
and not in the current folder,
Matlab will ask you whether you
want to change folders or add
it to the path.
And you can answer whatever
makes sense to you.
For a function, you need
to add the keyword function
in the beginning of your file.
Function f to c.
So let's write a function that
accepts Fahrenheit and converts
it to Celsius.
So return value, name
of the function, input.
And now we want to
say something like b
equals n minus 32 times 5/9.
Now v becomes this number.
And that is the conversion
between Fahrenheit and Celsius.
So this value v will be returned
to whoever calls this function.
We need to save it.
MATLAB already suggests f to c.
And we can put it inside
Scripts next to Fibbo.
Now we can write it
as a function f to c.
We need to give it an input.
If we don't give it an
input, we get an error.
So if we type 32, we get 0.
If we type 101, we get
this as a function.
You can either end your
function in the file or not.
This mostly affects the behavior
when you have sub-functions.
And will talk about
this in the future.